Through citizens arrested
The alleged seven iliders were brought to the police station
Recruiter
Who is said to have been victimized more
One hundred applicants
Who wants to work abroad
Approx
At forty million pesos
The suspect got it
From the victims
Karen de Guzman patrols
Complained to qcpd station fifteen
These applicants
Allegedly defrauded by a travel documentation agency
In barangay ramon
Tell a story
Quezon City
One of the victimized domestic helpers
alias Mayet
Enticed to apply as housekeeping staff
In poland
The salary is good
He said it was hundreds of thousands a month
Then I asked everyone how the process
That's how sweet they said
Promises
It mortgaged their house and land in Pangasinan
To pay two hundred
Seventy thousand pesos placement fee
But he didn't fly
Of course,
it's very painful
I'm not the only one,
almost all of us are
Because we just got together
That's why we're fighting ma'am
Aslystos owed half a million pesos
Assuming that they can also leave their husbands
To Poland
In the twenties of September
That match was said to be made during the government's holiday
We gave it because they have an alibi
It's october nine
They really designed that there is no match ah
They said they will no longer be posted
This is where we found out that it really is a scam
That's when we found out
It seems that we have weakened because we will pay for that
They also complained of fake visas and contracts
From the agency
It was found that there was no corresponding permit
Over one hundred and fifty
The victims they asked for money
In exchange for a promise to work in poland canada
New zealand and australia
They have no business
Affirmated to operate here in quezon city
And that's our verification of the poaa
At the department of michael workers is ah
We are still waiting for the result
The suspects defended themselves
And said that they are also victims of modus operandi
I am also an applicant
I'm not always there when someone just accompanies me
I'm the driver sir
ah,
I just got involved in what they are doing,
sir
An illegal recruitment complaint will be filed
At sindicated estafa
The suspects
While searching for their other two companions